I am a believer in the perfectibility of
human beings as a circle we can finally
realize our potential when we are our
best selves there isn't a problem that
we cannot solve we can cure any disease
and we can and hunger imagine the human
rights implications the possibilities
are endless your payment it was for 78
13 and the bill was for 78 31 thank you
you got the job at the circle have a
drink have a good time and stay excited
there at the circle not Amy how are you
Jarrod here we'll be doing a training I
first started it took me a few weeks to
really get the hang of it believe me
you're doing fine she come visit me at
work sometime you might think I was
there to clean the toilets
everyone really likes you your works in
exemplary strong readings but your
absence at several events sorry my dad
had an episode and I was home helping
out is that related to his MS I've been
looking into your parents situation and
I have an idea
I was thinking it would make sense for
amazed Oaks to come on the circle health
plan I want to say how much I value what
you've done for my family now you're a
valued part of the circle we care about
everybody you care about me he's only
been with us for a few months but she
has made quite an impression so mate do
you think you behave better or worse
when you are being watched
we have cameras in place all over the
world right now that's we used to go on
adventures they used to have fun and see
things and now it's all filtered through
this does this really seem okay to you
[Music]
I didn't create this this is not what I
had in mind
except the circle they need to change
everything recorded scene broadcast this
stored and analyzed here
I can use it however they see fit no
matter what its cost
knowing is good
knowing everything is bad
so mate is there anything you want to
tell us what chaos of the web made
elegant speed round Paul or John early
Paul late John Mario or Sonic early
sonic late Mario needs of the society or